Let's talk about why hijacks matter. Let's suppose
that you would like to visit a particular
Website. To do so you first need to issue a DNS query. Now the authoritative DNS
server for a particular domain might be located
in a distant network. As we've discussed in
previous lessons, The DNS uses a hierarchy to
direct your query to the location of the authoritative
name server, but ultimately that authoritative name
server has an IP address, and you use
the internet's routing protocol, the border gateway protocol,
to reach that IP address. What if an
attacker were running a rogue DNS server And
wanted to hijack your DNS query. Or to
return a false IP address. Well, the attacker
might use BGP to advertise a route for
the IP prefix that contains. That
authoritative DNS server. And suddenly your DNS
queries that were previously going to
the legitimate server, are instead redirected to
the rouge DNS server. So we might think of this as an attack where by an
attacker can use the DGP infrastructure to hijack a DNS. Query,
and masquerade as a legitimate service. It can get even worse than this.
Let's now look at how a BGP route hijack can result in a Man in
the Middle attack, whereby your traffic ultimately
reaches the correct destination, but the attacker
successfully inserts themselves on the path. The
problem with this particular route hijack. Is that
all traffic destined for IP X is going
to head for the attacker, even the traffic
from the legitimate network. What we'd like to
instead have happened is that traffic for IP X
first goes to the hijack location and then
goes to the legitimate location. So the attacker effectively
becomes a Man In The Middle. The problem
is that we need to somehow disrupt the routes
to the rest of the internet while
leaving the routes between the attacker and the
legitimate location intact. So that traffic along this
path can still head towards the legitimate AS.